[Music]
let's go
out to the opposite of Texas Anchorage
Alaska and talk yeah that's right
Anchorage Alaska let's talk to kendle
what is up
Kendall hi Dr John how are you doing
today paryan what are you up
to not
much what's
up um so I I guess I'll kind of fill you
in on what's going on and then ask my
question um so my mom just started
dating uh after 11 years since my dad
passed away um and my mom says that uh
he makes her super happy and treats her
well but he has a really concerning past
and current behaviors that are
worrisome and I have two little sisters
who are still living at home who won't
even be in the same room as him and part
of that is
definitely um the change of my mom
dating for the first time but they voed
that they're not comfortable around him
and he hasn't shown much effort into
getting to know them and then the other
part of this is he has a lot to gain
from dating or possibly married my mom
she's not super rich but she has a lot
of assets and he um only has a
car so I'm just kind of looking for help
how old how old are you Kendall uh 22 22
okay how old are your
sisters um 18 and 11
okay
um what was your dad's name uh Ed Ed was
he pretty awesome yeah you still have
some good memories of
him yeah how'd he pass
away um sorry no it's
okay take your time
I he had a random heart attack while we
were all out hiking oh man I'm so sorry
when I was
11 my
goodness and so my mom was left as a
single mom with five kids after that
jeez
wow and that's still right there at the
surface huh you miss him don't
you yeah it's been
tough just processing through someone
else being there yeah
well that that's my first uh that was
going to be my first question sometimes
red flags
emerge just because this new guy is not
my dad and my dad was freaking awesome
yeah and it's easy to look at um I was
just talking to my buddy Jefferson this
morning when you're a kid like I have a
life before my kids right yeah my kids
don't I'm their whole
life and now you're trying to wrap your
head around what who was your whole life
and then this just fog that's been the
last 10 years and then this guy shows up
right so you know that inherently
there's going to be some tension and
weirdness there right for sure okay um
so tell you said he's got a past what
past are you worried about um so he's
he's been married two times which you
know that's okay but um he's had three
restraining orders left against him oh
there's that lead with that next time
kindall um which what about with your
daughter I mean your sisters what are
they experiencing inside that home um so
there's a lot of there's a lot of
tension um a part of I think why they
mainly don't is my mom gets really
defensive of the boyfriend against my
sisters
okay um which since the restraining
orders he is sober which is definitely
something
um but he also kind of acts like a child
yeah um yeah when the government has to
step in and tell you to act like an
adult like a mature
person
um multiple times for crying out loud
I'll give you one if you have a bad
weekend right but my goodness um yeah so
why is your 18-year-old sister still
living at
home
um she
she's a little slower to adap to the
world I guess is the nicest way to put
it um driver intellectually or she's
just slow playing the
world just kind of slow very sheltered
okay um if you're 11-year-old sister if
you offered to let her move in with you
would she do
that she's already joking about moving
out I know but she can't cuz she's a
minor but if she moved in with you an
adult or one of your other siblings um
you've got two other sibling somewhere
yes okay um would she be able to do
that um if it came to it probably okay
let's let's let's play this out that you
and your sister sat down with your mom
and you said hey I have invited little
sister to come live with me and I'll get
her to school and back and um I want her
to just experience this what would your
mom say to that would she go oh my gosh
never or or would she say I think that'd
be
best um she'd probably really freak out
and he he isn't living with her or
anything
MH
um but I think she'd really freak out
okay um it might come to that level of
seriousness if you have this much
concern a couple of things I want to
caution you about not caution you about
but just expand your scope of what
you're seeing number one it's not your
dad
right right that's a big
one number and and nobody can ever live
up to the legend of that man that's in
your memory right right number
two um he does have a concerning past he
does very concerning past and as you
mentioned it sounds like maybe he's
putting the work in to make some
changes yeah my mom says he's he's going
to therapy and
you know he's he's trying to work
through all of his past and is hurt
okay um the third thing is we're going
to be very very concerned about the
safety of that 11-year-old girl yeah and
so um you and you have no legal
ramification at all unless you see
something that is concerning right you
hear about abuse you're about screaming
you hear about somebody punch a hole
through the sheetrock you hear about
taking your mom's money that kind of
stuff absent that I want you to begin
being very very intentional about
creating a relationship with this
11-year-old we go to breakfast every
week once a week just me and her right
right and you're G to have to as a 22y
old you don't have to you're a sister
but um sounds like you're super invested
which I'm proud of you um I want you to
invest heavily in the relational side
that way if anything pops up you're the
first call yeah and you're a safe place
your 18-year-old sister I think you need
to take her out and say hey it's time we
grow up real fast you're 18 years old
yeah this little I'm just going to stay
here cuz the rent is free because I
don't have to drive anywhere those days
are over now you're 18 years
old yeah and maybe she pays rent to you
and moves in with your apartment or
whatever the situation is but um I think
those are the different situ the
different conversations I'm going to
have with my sister right absent
breaking the law and absent
abuse um
your 11-year-old sister canot like this
guy all she wants but your mom's the
adult and your mom's her guardian yeah
right and if he's following all of his
probationary you know restrictions and
he's following all the rules of his
restraining orders then it is what it is
yeah what you can do is strengthen your
two sisters with your relationship and
your presence being a safe place that
your mom maybe is not right now yeah
does that sound
fair yeah and that's it's kind of what
I've been thinking and I've just been um
like not mean but very blunt with my mom
about things like he he came to the
house the other day and the 18 he was
like anybody home an 18-year-old was
like no go away and he stormed out of
the
house and called my mom this is over I
can't handle the disrespect and d d good
good and he should not be alone at home
he shouldn't be alone at home with an
18-year-old girl yeah and I think that's
the conversation with your mom mom he
has no business here being alone with an
18-year-old girl yeah oh he's not going
to do nothing he has no business being
here alone with an 18-year-old girl it's
not his
daughter yeah and if he had any brains
at
all he wouldn't walk in a front door
like
that right
yeah and so um May maybe the
conversation with your mom is Mom I'm
scared for you have y all gone and just
had like a lunch together like a quiet
or has it always end up when there's a
an issue then it turns into a
fight um I was thinking about taking her
out I just wanted to do this call First
and pick your brain yeah um but even
when I talk to her it's it doesn't it's
not like fighting she just kind of like
oh well he's a good guy so I think
there's something to be said for hey Mom
I can't imagine
how like in the depths of Hell lonely
you've been for the last
decade and maybe say I miss dad so much
this idiot on a podcast the other day
asked me about her oh no I said I wasn't
going to say I was an idiot anymore this
guy on a podcast um asked me about Dad
and I started crying I miss him so much
yeah and say Mom I know you're so so
lonely and I need you to know this guy
makes me really
uncomfortable yeah he makes me not feel
safe and if you say he's great and
wonderful and so kind and loving
okay but I need you to hear me say he
makes me not feel safe and I'm worried
about my
sisters that's a very different that's
you taking it as an adult woman that's
you owning your feelings you owning the
way you're experiencing this not saying
you need to be doing this and you need
to be doing that because if if you do
that to her she's GNA have to fight you
back but if you sit down and say I have
bad vibes on this there's a bad track
record here I'm worried he's just trying
to take your money I I I just don't feel
good about it and also God you must be
lonely right both
and you're acknowledging the the the
just mess that she's been in for so long
right and maybe tell
her gosh
man you know what no one's probably told
her in 10
years how proud they are of
her yeah because the day after your dad
passed away she had to go be a mom to
five kids all by
herself then the day after that and then
the day after that and then 10 years
later she's still doing
it yeah and there's something to be said
for holding your mom's hand across the
table and saying I'm like so proud of
you thank you yeah
right and sometimes when we're lonely we
go chasing somebody that will tell us on
I see you got value he may see that
she's got value and assets right and
things he could take from her um or that
she's a A desperate woman and she'll you
know she'll make out with him or
whatever which I know it's gross to
think about your mom but she's a person
too but he he may you know he he may
want to see value in other things but
having her daughter her adult daughter
sit across a table from her and just say
no no no Mom I see you but this guy
makes me feel uncomfortable
um that's a different conversation than
how having a big disagreement in the
house or a big fight in the house or he
storms off and makes a call then she's
embarrassed so she bombs you guys that's
that's this is just a different way to
handle it it may change nothing but at
least you know I did the right thing and
I I voiced what I was experiencing as an
adult in an adult mature way and I
treated my mom with dignity and respect
and yet I told the truth all of that is
to be
commended and continue to build
relationships with your sisters and hear
me say at the first sign of abuse at the
first sign of something's not right let
your mom absolutely know Mom I'm calling
911 I'm calling the police I'm not going
through you I'm not going through him
I'm going straight to the authorities
not going to have any wonky play in my
house and with my sisters there I think
just let everybody know I'm kall 22
years old I'm Standing Tall I'm an adult
woman I've had a hard go of it I miss my
dad and I'm proud of my mom but I'm
drawing some firm boundaries in my life
I'm proud of you proud of you call
anytime let me know how that
conversation goes because I'd love to
hear how your mom responds to that my
guess is she may respond in a more
receptive way than you think I'm proud
of
you